yeah I kind of clear my throat before
this one too yeah this will clear our
throats for us Y and everything else
okay this is the bomb Beyond insanity
this was the one you warned me about
this one yeah am I allowed to say that
okay this next one is the bomb Beyond
Insanity
pass it is a sauce of the reputation
that precedes yeah I heard about this
one yeah so this is a real Cho is real
cheers all right I'll go you cheers
cheers how much do we do oh you're
already in bye mhm game over that's
plenty oh God okay here we go see you in
the bathroom all right oh I can smell it
a ready cuz that's that's a Reaper isn't
it in there oh Jesus yeah that that goes
immediate whoo yeah
immediately all right I didn't even get
that thing in my like on my teeth and it
hit me we're just driving oh it's hot
yeah immediately was when it got here I
knew it was going to be bad yeah and
that's saying a lot I've done a lot of
damage to my
synapses I'm really nervous and I can
hear the editing on the background
is music getting
higher reaching fever patch here it
comes
yeah hello Mama yeah please tell me it's
downhill from here please so it'll
probably continue to grow on us just a
little bit really right it's getting
hotter it's [__] it's increasing
grows and gross
bro holy
[__] yo you got to be [__] kidding me
bro my body's like this is poison and
you yeah right like once like reject I
think my leg just
cramped wait why the ears Sean ears I
don't know about like are they like
popping like an airplane kind of yep my
throat's posing up oh God why why [__]
that
sauce yeah yeah
[__] are you for real I'm
fine oh my God I know I can't even get
to the water holy [__] going for the uh
lifelines when does it stop
burning does this
help I think what you're find
is that nothing actually helps you know
like once you're in this thing there's
nothing that truly saves you I don't
know what nothing helps I know I know I
know I know it just gross it just gross
like so much I get it I get it I get it
is my face
okay this sh got be crying I know I know
me too I a't said it to you so
long I'm you I know I'm I'm here I'm
right
here there it goes wow that dramatic
thanks I looked down the camera on
it that just burns everything in your
mouth I know I know and then here we are
on an interview show and I'm about to
ask you a question right so naturally
this show invites a lot of conversations
how you still talk I know you know I'm
eating chicken wings right now right I
know I know don't even talk don't me I'm
just going to chill I'm just going to
chill
[Music]
I'm just interpreting this abstract
dance over here oh careful careful
around the eyes careful around the eyes
yeah there we go that's better that's
better that's better you've done that
230 some odd times now yeah probably
closer to
300 [__] your mother why would you do
that many [__] [__] you up yeah every
time the discomfort that you feel I
catch it every single time oh my God but
I can get kind of a
weightlessness sort of head high mhm
that I think has been easier to shake
loose the more I do it I love you more
man I love you even I love you even more
rise up this is
beautiful oh my God whatever Magic
Carpet you're on right now I'm there
that's what I'm talking about let's ride
it this feels like that scene in Aladdin
when he's like get on the Magic Carpet
he's like do you trust me and I'm like
no Sean I don't [__] trust you
anymore right no I I get that I get that
I get that oh [__] you
sh it's a little spin yeah I know I
know if you want the smoke you can catch
the smoke I may have been raised by
white people on TV but you about to
catch a case right now son I shouldn't
have said that like I'm saying things I
see how you guys do it it's it disarms
this is a story structure to your
interview you tell me I'm I'm doing well
yeah and then you try to kill me yeah
yeah yeah well I see I mean it's got to
be successful for a reason what's your
legal
situation I think exposed honestly
you've got to have lawyers like around
the clock that's not even like for food
you know what I mean no that's just to
[__] with people it's no fun I don't
blame you fued I know it's [__] up I
feel like I'm going to die I know get it
they must have use military technology
to make that [__] that [__] is
crazy just a disgusting sauce that hurts
your mouth and probably your stomach
butthole in just a matter of moments why
would you buy this you're an idiot and
why would you make it I'll wear that
I'll wear that that's fact
[__]